hey kids das klima ist echt wichtig denn
sonst knallts hier bald richtig doch
jetzt haben wir sie ja endlich die
bundesumweltministerin frau hendrix
[Musik]
die bundesumweltministerin gilt als die
unbekannteste ministerin im aktuellen
kabinett das wollen wir ändern und frau
hendrix und ihre kampagne heute mal
vorstellen hendrix oder hinrichs hendrix
wissen sie wie die
bundesumweltministerin heißt nee nee nee
da fällt mir jetzt so spontan sich eine
wissen sie wie die
bundesumweltministerin heißt
ich mache einfach gibt es eine
bundesumweltministerium das ist auch
eine gute frage was noch einfacher gibt
es eine umwelt ja
was muss diese frau machen damit sie
wieder ein bisschen aufmerksamkeit
kriegt
ja was man halt so tun kann als frau
08 15 wie kann man das ändern kann man
ändern indem man erst mal die haare
anders macht auf jeden fall rot grün und
grün ein bisschen heller und denn nicht
ein bisschen stufig geschnitten oder was
nicht so hier sind ja fortschritt
teilnehmen auf der straße kennt sich
jemand höchste zeit dass ich sie auf
suche und barbara henrichs populärer und
regt hendrix barbara hendricks populärer
[Musik]
wie heißt
das ist die hendrix das ist die hendrix
wie können wir ihnen denn helfen ihre
kampagne cooler zu machen warum machen
sie doch einfach das licht aus das
verbraucht zu viel energie sie sind aber
streng er machte dem tier ist ein
bisschen runter sonst gibt es stress gut
wie ist denn der hashtag hier heute
eigentlich
zdk waren die kohlen herrscht schon alle
weg oder ich habe keine ahnung wie die
auf zig gekommen sind das klingt
zickenterror woran liegt das dass das
thema klimaschutz gerade nicht so super
hip ist auch das ist schon super hit da
waren noch mehrere hunderttausend
menschen in new york unterwegs ist wer
übrigens super wenn sie vor jedem
wichtigen wort immer hashtag sagen
können das mache ich nicht hashtag
verweigerung
was natürlich immer hilft bei einer
kampagne ein gemeinsames feindbild wir
dachten ankläger klimaschützer gegen
salafisten ehrlich gesagt dafür bringen
wir die leute nicht auf die straße aber
für positive sachen bringen die sich
schon auf die straße stell dir vor ist
es winter und keiner geht hin
das kann gut sein fokus jahr war winter
und er kam irgendwie nicht mama werden
wir morgen sterben ja
je nachdem wann morgen ist dann ist es
so ja
hey kids das klima ist echt wichtig denn
sonst knallts ihr bald richtig doch
jetzt haben wir sie nicht die
bundesumweltministerin frau hendrix
also wenn sie noch fragen haben sich
einfach noch mal nicht den man ja jetzt
macht das licht auch mal auch unter
jetzt kinder ja war da nicht ganz nett
oder die henrichsmann hendriks
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbole bei uns im neuen studio gefunden
wie laminat die freimaurer staatsführung
ist alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekanntgeben
erst bei so vielen abonnenten auf
youtube
also ich würde mich ran halten